agustín pas millo no ha podido
reabastecer su puesto de verduras y
vegetales en el mercado popular de la
ciudad de quito las movilizaciones
indígenas que comenzaron hace más de una
semana está llevando a perder su negocio
por la falta de inventario no llegan los
productos
nos llegan los alimentos y lo poco que
llegas llegaba muy caro a veces hasta se
duplica el precio del precio original
otros con menor suerte han decidido
cerrar su puestos y ya no cuentan con
alimentos para vender y la situación
tiende a no mejorar cuando la
distribución del combustible está
presentando un retraso ya siete
provincias del país tienen problemas de
abastecimiento según datos de la cámara
nacional de distribuidores de derivados
del petróleo pichincha es una de ellas y
los usuarios comenzaron a tomar sus
previsiones ante una posible escasez
comprar incluso unos galones de 4 o 5
litros para poder llenar la gasolina y
tenerla en la casa de reserva porque no
se sabe que pueda pasar con esta
situación pero otra parte de la
comunidad indígena de ecuador se está
viendo afectada con los bloqueos víctor
que maneja un emprendimiento familiar de
venta de artesanías y cuyos productos
provienen de una de las provincias
declaradas en emergencia se cuestiona si
debe salir a las calles o proteger su
negocio también es justo no es
es por una remuneración justa para el
trabajo del campo que no es bien
remunerado y por otro lado en mi trabajo
en mi enfoque del trabajo que es el
turismo ahí nos vemos los a todos
afectados las luchas indígenas son un
componente histórico de la protesta
social en ecuador que han logrado
derrocar cuatro gobiernos las más
recientes se produjeron en el año 2019
por las mismas causas que hoy consideran
y satisfechas esas demandas no cumplidas
afectan agustín que espera que las
movilizaciones no le obliguen a cerrar
los días pasan y el conflicto que ha
dejado el primer fallecido y 86
detenidos aún no avizora una pronta
solución